will Greer here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you will I'm doing well man
thanks for having me on
you bet so is is Steph Curry kind of
like a legend in your Oh your hometown
well absolutely
I actually used to I used to go to
Davidson basketball games back when he
was absolutely bawling and then in
college is fun to watch I bet
what was that like how old were you when
you were watching Steph
later I was uh you know middle school
high school he was uh actually I was
born in Charlotte but I lived in
Davidson for about six or so years my
mom did and I used to I could walk to
the to the basketball state of the
Coliseum they have in Davidson hmm so I
used to go that watch a whole lot of
games with Bob McKillip over there he's
still their guest for head coach and but
that was fun to go to man and stuff
obviously an unbelievable basketball
player so absolutely and you are ballin
out sir you are absolutely ballin out
what was it like to I guess go back and
have your coach Dana Holgorsen say who
wants to win the game let's go win the
game in Texas will ya notice also I mean
he it shows the kind of the trustee has
in me and confidence in me as a player
and you know we've obviously spent a lot
of time together the past few years and
then he you know he really trusts my
understanding of the game and you know I
just put through all the talks we've had
and you know how much how much film and
ball we've just talked and watched you
know he he's got a lot of trust in me
and some of the other guys frankly on
the on this team some we got some older
some leaders and guys that played a lot
of football have a lot of experience and
you know we talked about on the
sidelines you know we were gonna go down
and score and and go win this game no I
know I know
again you've you've more recently
destroyed TCU but just as for that game
in Texas to win that game the way in
which you want it did you know going
into that final drive that your coach is
planning to go for to if you scored yeah
we talked about it on the sidelines I
we had that two-point play that we
hadn't used yet and we you know wrapped
it you know every week this year and I
was confident in and I knew that you
know this is a play that gives me
options and you know move we were
talking on the sidelines and we knew
that we were gonna go score and it was
we were ready to use it and ready to go
for two and then win the game so yeah we
were we were confident in the play and
and like I said dana has a lot of trust
in us as you know an offense and he
knows that you know with that play with
the options I have that I would do
whatever it took to get us in the end
zone all right so now you're one of six
teams from currently ranked four all the
way down to nine with one loss pound the
table for why you should be in the Final
Four
well yeah well I mean you know that's
that's you know obviously out of our
control and not something that as a team
that we're focused on you know we're
we're focused on being want to know
every week and controlling the you know
what we can control I think we're a
really good football team I think that
like I mentioned we have a lot of you
know older guys some of some guys with a
lot of experience that you know are good
leaders that at this point in the season
can pick up some of these younger guys
and help us finish strong
you know we've played a lot of good
teams this year this is the big 12 is a
really good league there's a lot of
teams that you know records are not the
best but have been in tough games with
almost everybody we got one of those
this week you know Oklahoma State's an
outstanding football team that's beat a
couple good football teams and been in
close games with a lot of good football
teams you know it's really competitive
league a lot of good coach there's a lot
of good players in this league and it's
tough to win and I'm really proud of our
team in the way we've been able to win
and at this point it's about going want
to know the rest of the way and
finishing this season's season strong
well obviously wins at Oklahoma state in
Oklahoma your next two opponents would
certainly grab some attention there's no
doubt about that and then what about
your owner Heisman hope will
what are you thinking off what about
that I understand it's a team game but
there is an eye on will and Greer
yeah no the I mean you said it it's a
teams form it's a team game the fact
that I'm even in the conversation is an
honor and I would love to bring that
home here to West Virginia I think would
be great for the for the state in this
program and I would love to win that
it's another thing that is you know
ultimately I'm not I don't I don't get
to vote but you know it's like you said
it's a team sport I wouldn't be here
without the players and coaches that I'm
with every day and then what they've
done and you know really proud of the
way that our defense and our o-line
receivers running backs the way we've
come together and really found our
identity and as you know played with
effort and passion and hard every week
and gotten to where we're at right now
and like I said our focus is on
finishing the season strong and you know
if that means I get the Heisman that
would be great do you think the big 12
gets overlooked well you know I don't I
don't know if you know I'm in a position
to say what's overlooked or what's not
are your career West Virginia
quarterback I will say that it's an
extremely competitive league and with a
lot of a lot of talent I mean it's a
tough tough league to play and we play
everybody and you know every week is a
challenge you know you watch film you
see a lot of the same you know guys
playing each other obviously and and
it's a it's a really competitive league
a lot of good a lot of good coaches a
lot of good players a lot of good
programs and it's tough to play all
these guys back-to-back and that offer
different challenges almost every week
well I mean the MVP of the National
Football League could be a Texas Tech
head the number one overall pick in the
Football League this past past year is
an Oklahoma kid and the NFL I you know
likes guys who are 6 3 and above at
quarterback who also have a wife and a
kid coming out of college who's in their
mid to early 20s as well you kind of
check all those boxes will Grier are you
thinking about the next level at any
point in time yeah it's
not a huge focus of mine but I feel
extremely prepared you know I'm you know
clearly I think Pat mahomes is is you
know excelling at the next level and I
you know I'm familiar with the offense
he runs I know cliff Kings very pretty
well and you know spavin him are very
close and do a lot of the same things
offensively and no Baker I think he's an
outstanding player and I mean there's
like I said they were they were in these
you know big 12 battles they played a
lot this league has been strong it's
been strong for a long time and I feel
fully prepared to you know play at the
next level
you know I think that I'm mentally and
physically ready but my focus right now
is on winning games for West Virginia
okay well I mean if you keep going we'll
maybe you can wind up on Dancing with
the Stars like your 18 year old brother
Hayes or word nine million Instagram
followers like the 20 year old brother
Nash those guys have been dominating
social media for a couple years right
now is it true would you say you're the
third most popular Greer of your of your
family not here on the Rich Eisen show
but I'm just saying overall out in the
population so without a doubt without
though their extremes way more popular
than I am and I I could never do Dancing
with the Stars I'm I was very impressive
and very proud of Hayes for for doing
that that's not easy and he did a great
job now yeah I mean he was 15 when he
did if I'm not mistaken day was that's
not easy to do and with no dancing
background he went out and did a good
job I was proud of all right well it's
very rare that I ask a guest of the show
who can win a Heisman Trophy and a
national championship would you mind
asking your brothers to repost the video
of this conversation later on but I'm
not ashamed I have no shame no shame
though I mean you know come on Chris
Brockman Bravo my honor my RI compadre
the 11 million Twitter followers
combined amongst the the two Nash
brothers well rich I'm already ahead of
you I tagged them in the notification
you don't mind well deal was on you
don't mind I don't mind I'll give them a
call right after this okay thank you
because there's an eye on rich and Eisen
too you know what I'm saying common
hey we'll really enjoy watching the way
you ball out and and I know you you
carry the hopes of a lot of diehard West
Virginia football fans so good luck down
the line and hopefully we'll chat again
soon
yes sir no doubt I really appreciate it
thanks for having me on bet that's will
Grier who I might actually see in
Indianapolis as well the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience